con piedras y palos los palestinos de la
blusa y Jordania ocupada atacaron a las
fuerzas israelíes que entraron al
territorio en busca de posibles
militantes sospechosos de planear
atentados inminentes
a las 9:30 las fuerzas especiales
entraron en la zona a las 9:48 se oyó
una explosión que me despertó y miré por
la ventana y vi a las fuerzas especiales
con perros
y estaban conectando cables Que supongo
que eran TNT Dios sabe
la facción militante Palestina yihadi
islámica anunció que dos de sus
comandantes fueron cercados en una casa
por tropas israelíes los soldados
mataron a los sospechosos y a otros 8
palestinos hirieron a más de 100 durante
la incursión adnan le advirtió a su
padre que era mejor que no volviera a
casa por el momento
por la mañana mi padre salió de la casa
para comprar algunas cosas Entonces el
ejército israelí hizo una incursión en
el barrio me llamó y me preguntó si
había soldados en el barrio así que le
dije que sí que no volviera están
rodeando el barrio por todas partes de
repente Alguien me llamó y me dijo que
mi padre estaba herido yo estaba en mi
casa hacediada pude salir cuando el
ejército abandonó la ciudad
han sido objeto de incursiones por parte
de Israel intensificadas en el último
año en respuesta a mortíferos atentados
en ciudades israelíes 61 palestinos
entre hombres armados y civiles han
muerto en 2023 en el Ministerio de
sanidad palestino de israelíes murieron
en ataques palestinos en el mismo
periodo según el Ministerio de asuntos
exteriores de Israel